in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Luke
and Megan are with us hey guys how are
ya hi great welcome welcome
and where do you guys live Kansas City
all right welcome to Nashville thank you
all the way here to do your debt-free
scream yes sir
awesome and how much did you pay off
thirty four thousand five hundred right
around there very good and how long did
that take uh 16 months excellent
and range of income and the household
during that time well it's we started as
an engaged couple so Luke was making a
little over seventy in the military I
was making about fifty right out of
college I paid off about half of that on
my own at eight months and he cash
flowed our wedding and nice guy and yeah
and then the next eight months of being
married we were probably about a little
over seventy now as he's transitioning
into a software coding job okay very
cool well thank you for your service it
was a pleasure good deal very fun very
fun what kind of debt was the thirty
five thousand is all Meg's yep meg what
kind of debt did you have uh student
loans primarily tiny bit of car debt but
mostly student loans and so what made
you decide to that paying it off was
part of this getting married idea I just
I am a CPA small business owner and so I
like it's just kind of my nature to want
to plan for finances and so I was
already on your track had no money he
had plenty of savings no debt but no
plan so I convinced him very cool sure
he got you got you got him on board and
he obviously financed the wedding you
get married and this thing is knocked
out the rest of the way yeah she
convinced me because well so before we
met I was saving money every month and
then I met her and I was spending more
than I made so after about six months of
watching my bank account go down every
month when we were sitting to McDonald's
I said babe this is it this is month I
run out of money like I'll see what
happens next mouth I'm just like you are
doing a budget on board
it's fun the McDonald's budget meeting
yes there it is that's when the war
that's where the worm turn right change
the whole trajectory very cool and you
got married how long ago about a year
ago okay all right very cool well
congratulations so when people ask how
you got out of that what are you telling
the keys to getting out of debt are you
know for me the big difference between
people who do it and people who don't is
you have to stop making rationalizations
like in our country people you just
assume you each have to have a car you
assume you have to buy a house before
you have kids it's we think we're
entitled to those things but for us
saying no to a lot of those normal
20-some events early on means that we'll
get to do those things later when we've
actually earned the right to do them so
stop rationalizing is my big wow my big
recommend good for you oh cool your
parents hear you talk like that they're
probably proud of you I hope so they're
watching I think we'll get them on your
plane here it's also gotta get them to a
McDonald's there we go take them to
McDonald's yeah you can't leave until
you get your budget done no Big Mac for
you bad that's it I love it well
congratulations you guys what was the
hardest part of this for you all um I
think for me it was not going out to eat
when I was singling in the military I'd
out every night Sharon's lunch was you
know anything I wanted to go to today
yeah
so I missed that and then yeah he had a
miserable job for a while and as a wife
and supporter I really wanted him to cut
ties from that but the debt like really
drove us to say we have the income we
need to keep it so I think just a
freedom to make life choices that are
you know you're not as enslaved I guess
so yeah so now that it's all done how
does it feel pretty good baby is what
we're saving for now like we now we know
we could buy a house with cash that's
our next plan is give us the confidence
to do that you know so it's just a
confidence booster really that's fun
once a baby due August 11 Oh coming up
fast yeah yeah you're just about to the
point you didn't need to come I know
Kelly asked when are you due
that's it right there yeah right on
target well very cool congratulations
you guys you're Charlotte young couple
you're heroes you're in control you're
winning and you know I meet more
Millennials that are like you than I
meet the what kinds the deadbeats that
everybody talks about I don't eat more
like you there's a lot of you good ones
out there so very very cool good for you
all right
Luke and Megan $35,000 paid off in 16
months making him 120 down to 70 now
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one well Don you two
very very well done that's how it is
that's awesome and what their future is
so bright it is unbelievable where
they're gonna be in 10 years they can't
they can't see it as clear as I can I've
just watched it happen for 30 years now
it's really really unbelievably huge
excellent excellent excellent hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show and so
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind